alexis poulain merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france ce discours
comment vous l'avez perçu comment vous
les analyser mais c'est une mise en
scène où emmanuel macron une fois encore
essaye d'endosser les habits d'un ancien
président cette fois ci c'est plutôt le
général de gaulle qui en cette même date
en 1958 avait sur la place de la
république présentées et bien ce nouveau
projet de constitution pour la vème
république
il fait état bien sûr de gambetta mais
pour d'autres la république française à
une autre date de naissance est le 22
septembre 1792 à la convention où
finalement on décide d'arrêter avec la
monarchie
donc c'est bien une façon de s'inscrire
dans la continuité plutôt gaulliste
cette fois-ci de la république et de
mettre bien une première étape vers
cette loi contre le séparatisme il l'a
dit
parce qu'il a parlé beaucoup de liberté
il a parlé beaucoup de devoirs bien sûr
des citoyens mais il a oublié la
fraternité qui est pourtant et bien
consubstantiel de la république il ya le
rappelle aussi de la laïcité du droit de
blasphémer d'abord en lien avec le
procès de charlie en ce moment que s'est
ouvert il ya deux jours à votre avis que
penseraient les penseurs de l'époque
justement de l'état de notre laïcité
aujourd'hui la laïcité c'est un combat
qui est arrivé justement pour la
troisième république à la fin du 19e
siècle
parce que l'église avait trop
d'importance dans les affaires de la
nation qu'il a fallu est bien installé
cette république avec les hussards noirs
de la république et c'est l'éducation
qui était au coeur du projet républicain
y compris au coeur du proche du premier
projet républicain de la première
république
aujourd'hui on voit bien que l'éducation
n'est pas une des priorités des manuels
macron il a souhaité bonne rentrée
depuis liban la rentrée a été préparé de
manière assez chaotique par jean michel
blanquer
et pourtant c'est l'éducation qui fait
qu'on pourrait avoir et bien des
citoyens libres conscients qu'ils savent
qu'ils peuvent avoir une liberté de
parole
et puis la liberté de parole en france
elle est toute relative par exemple
beaucoup de livres rien ne peuvent pas
tout
en france et doivent trouver des
éditeurs à l'étranger c'est le cas du
livre de juan branco c'est le cas du
livre d'eric stemmelen l'opération macro
qui sont publiés par des éditeurs belges
ou suisses parce que eh bien
en france on a la liberté de parole
jusqu'à un certain point donc oui il
faut rappeler les valeurs républicaines
mais il faut les vivre
et encore une fois elles sont simples
liberté égalité fraternité
et puis elles sont listées dans la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen de 1789 ça ça ne faisait pas
partie de l'adresse demel macron ce
matin alors temps forts de son discours
lorsqu'elle a évoqué les séparatismes on
que faut-il comprendre dans les propos
d' emmanuel macron et que peut faire la
république face au communautarisme
alors oui effectivement et des
maquereaux va dérouler en maintenant
cette lutte contre le séparatisme qui
vise bien entendu le terrorisme
islamique
mais d'autres et particulièrement celui
ci parce que ça a été des discours qu'on
a entendu déjà qu'il a mis des jalons et
que gérald darmanin va être là pour
travailler sur ce sujet là la république
elle est là elle a toujours été là pour
protéger
il faut maintenant mettre en place des
politiques qui le font nous avons des
services de renseignement qui déjoue des
attentats de chaque mois les ça
fonctionne
heureusement mais aujourd'hui le
problème
il est dans la formation dans le
recrutement de possibles futurs
terroristes djihadistes ou autre ou bien
le communautarisme tout simplement le
fait de refuser les valeurs de la
république
mais au-delà de cette cible évidente qui
est celui du communautarisme religieux
il y a aussi des gens qui refusent tout
simplement les valeurs de la république
en se soustrayant à l'impôt en
organisant l'évasion fiscale c'est une
autre façon et bien d'être séparatiste
las il n'en est pas question dans les
discours des modèles macro et pourtant
c'est un séparatisme comme un autre et
sur la question justement de la lutte
contre le racisme
l'égalité des chances c'est ce que la
sortie de my own accroc est une est
réussi ou pas salon
bah c'est égal à lui-même disons que il
a le fait le choix là justement de se
mettre en scène avec des gens qui se
naturaliser français qui ont des
parcours exceptionnel il y avait un
médecin libanaise et d'autres personnes
qui étaient là dans de la cérémonie de
ce matin
oui c'est important de lutter contre le
racisme c'est incroyable qu'on en soit
d'ailleurs encore là dans notre pays
alors que les lois existent que c'est un
délit et que malheureusement on voit que
le travail d'éducation et bien est
encore à faire
le racisme il est partout présent pas
seulement en france et c'est bien
malheureux mais on a en france un devoir
justement parce que l'universel est là
il l'a rappelé d'ailleurs que cette
république française
elle est particulière parce qu'elle fait
écho dans le monde entier par sa
déclaration des droits de l'homme
eh bien nous devons être à la hauteur de
cette déclaration des droits de l'homme
nous citoyens mais encore une fois ça
passera par une éducation forte et par
des valeurs fortes qui sont rappelées
quotidiennement est ce qu'à votre avis
emmanuel mac est à l'aise avec un pan de
l'histoire la troisième république
l'histoire colonialiste selon vous
alors non personne est à l'aise la
république a beaucoup de mal avec cette
histoire coloniale et d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça qu'on a autant de problèmes avec
les cette histoire des colonials le
déboulonnage des statuts la cancel
culture comme certains peuvent l'appeler
on a un problème parce que en europe
nous ne connaissons pas l'histoire de
l'afrique nous avons une culture
extrêmement parcellaires nous ne
connaissons rien des empires africains
et tout ce que nous connaissons de cette
histoire elle est par la colonisation
c'est-à-dire que nous avons créé une
histoire africaine qui n'est pas
l'histoire du continent africain loin de
là eh bien ça il faut y remédier bien
entendu il faut s'en séparer il faut
faire bien l'audit de ce qui a été
l'horreur de la colonisation parce qu'il
faut appeler qui a été le cas alors
certains vous diront que c'était
apporter la civilisation à d'autres non
ça a été et bien un jour imposée à des
populations locales pour beaucoup avec
des violences qui ont été documentés
dans certains livres certaines
publications et le livre noir de la
colonisation par exemple et d'autres
donc c'est important de faire cet
aggiornamento
et puis de de voir que maintenant nous
allons passer à autre chose mais nous
devons vivre avec le passé et c'est ce
passé là qui ne doit pas aujourd'hui est
un problème pour le présent et surtout
construire un futur commun tiens
justement puisque vous faisiez allusion
à l'histoire aux pays d'afrique est
justement là alassane ouattara le
président ivoirien que dont le troisième
mandat et contester la candidature est
contestée de rencontre emmanuel macron
vers 13 heures
à votre avis là il va tranche emmanuel
macron c'est tout à fait possible on le
voit de toute façon depuis cette rentrée
politique se mettre en scène à
l'international donc pourquoi ne
serait-il pas là encore aventureux dans
la façon dont il va traiter le problème
ivoirien
il a été au liban il ya bien sûr le mali
il y en a d'autres
et là ça va être encore une fois est
bien un test sur la politique africaine
de la france
il faut arrêter avec la françafrique il
est temps d'arrêter on voit bien que les
français les différents gouvernements
français et ont bien du mal à arrêter
avec des pays amis comme on le dit parce
que c'est une sphère d'influencé
importante
il y à la francophonie qui reste
extrêmement importante pour la france en
afrique et au delà donc bea emmanuel
macron peut être fidèle à lui-même et
prendre une décision cavaliere
cet après midi merci à vous à l'écrit
poulain rappelle que vous êtes
éditorialistes cofondateur de la revue
le monde moderne